ص عنيف جدا في الساحه الخلفيه لمستشفى
شهداء الاقصى الان اصابات وشهداء في
المستشفى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى يتعرض لقصف
الان جوي عنيف
جدا ساحه المستشفى ساحه المستشفى
الان الان ساحه المستشفى تتعرض لقصف
المبنى ال المبنى الخارجي للمستشفى تعرض
للقصف الان المبنى الخارجي للمستشفى
بداخلها عدد كبير جدا من
المواطنين من المواطنين
الان
الان الان قصف عنيف داخل المستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير
البلح الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه اغارت
قبل قليل على هذه البنايه على باب مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح اعداد كبيره
جدا من الاصابات والشهداء تم نقلهم من هذه
البنايه التي مازال المواطنون يحاولون
استخراج مزيد من المصابين والشهداء من
داخل هذا المنزل على باب مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى عدد كبير من النازحين قد اصيبوا
بجراح وعدد اخر ايضا هناك من الشهداء يتم
في هذه الاثناء محاوله اخراج هؤلاء الناس
من هذا المنزل البوابه ايضا بوابه
المستشفى قد تعرضت بشكل مباشر لاضرار
كبيره جدا المستشفى نفسه ايضا قد تضرر
وبشكل كبير مستشفى الشهداء الاقصى فقط
الغاره تبعد عن قسم الاستقبال والطوارئ
امتار قليله وبطئ الاف 16 اغارت على هذه
البنايه التي تم تدميرها بشكل كامل شاهدنا
اعداد كبيره من الشهداء والمصابين بين
المدنيين يتم نقلهم باتجاه مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى باتجاه قسم الاستقبال الذي تضرر
بشكل كامل ايضا جراء هذه الغاره اشرف ابو
عمره لقناه الجزيره امام مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح